[Music]
and welcome back to another Super Saucy
episode of the careful boys today we
have Jared and Dr Mike joining us
today Fitness and whether or not we stay
on topic we're going to start with a
prompt what is the greatest physical
pain you have ever felt or endured pH
wow phal physical using a nail gun
around your jadal usually
works why we using a nail gun around
your janal get nervous your hand gets
sweaty what you do sh the [__] up are
you serious right now you stapled your
nut sack to a 2x4 not a first of all
it's a nail gun we assuming a lot it's
not the nail going through the dick
that's the proximate problem cuz that's
like whatever you nailing your dick
every now and again excuse me bad
memories it's the fact that your dick is
now nailed into
something does not simply remove it what
was the something 2x4 2x4 oh my God just
like your dick or your balls you how
many of you fell seen some porn before
an adult fil or two
young yeah I'm just I'm still trying to
wrap my head around being naked around
yeah yeah yeah yeah no we'll get you
there uh step by step yeah it's great
show and and then so
at first you just just titties off a
[__] three and a half floppy disc man
[__] loads line by line that's good
enough yeah and then you need a little
something more yeah yeah yeah and you
keep years later you look more like
smeagle high precious and [__] like that
and you you don't even look human
anymore and you would just been jacking
off to Old weird [__] and there's this
internet porn but then there's that
bottom 10% of degeneracy where you're
like what is even going on I got below
that because there's levels to this they
say and they usually mean levels up like
black belts are so good there's levels
there's also levels now and so at some
point this the sheer danger of
construction equipment around my
genitals is the only thing getting me
across the Finish Line because another
thing Mead Channel viewers might be
relate to stop you have this idea in
your head this is what I want a jerk off
too like you know I'm saying see a [__]
on the bus and you're like scanning you
say [__] I got you zap but when you go
beyond
that when you go beyond that you're just
now the bus is what turns you on here's
the thing not even that first of all yes
getting your genitalia she like don't
look at me like that I'm like I'm
looking at the bus [__] and
uh uh but then you start Jay in the D so
to speak and then that thing you thought
was going to knock you over the edge it
just doesn't cut it you like you run her
ground very disappointing you're like
and you kind of get softer and you're
like but she was supposed to be the one
tonight so you get out the old nail
gun you pointed while at your genitals
it's the fear that dries the fear it's
like the adrenaline rush I just want to
be a little squealing tied up pit ever
wanted to be it was a roller coaster
yeah it was just a little bit of a
Thrill Ride it's fun did you buy the
nail gun just to jack off with or you
already had it no it was like my
grandpa's or
something see I thought you were role
playing and she's like be a construction
worker and you're like like this hey hey
babe and then like you're just like look
at this I'm working on projects yeah and
she goes oh you're man you're just like
yeah she's like do some masculine stuff
like oh yeah like carelessness and
disregard for my own safety bam cuz
that's masculine as [__] masculine women
care and [__] [__] I'm not trying to
care I'm trying to shoot my [__] dick
with a nail gun and I did it and it hurt
a lot at first and then I was like oh
I'm fine nope I'm not I'm still attack
you to pull out the
nail what didn't I do is a shorter list
try to ice sh I mean but also like what
was am I going to go to the hospital or
is this too embarrassing do I have
reputation to uphold or is this a
serious medical emergency we just
getting through it is good enough what
did you end up doing scary it was
frightening the entire time in the car
ride to the hospital I'm thinking like
what do I tell the nurse or whoever
checks you in cuz she's like gives you a
form to fill out [__] I don't have a
form watch this you fill this out to
describe and she's like did you get hurt
at work and I'm like I guess but I
wasn't like getting remunerated for it
or anything wasn't like my job I wasn't
clocked in but hey when I'm jerking off
I was clocked
in I take this
seriously so you were there with the 2x4
stuck right there with your penis what
did you do dude did you wrap a towel
around and then go okay towel yeah yeah
dry ice that turned out to be a bad idea
burn the [__] out of my dry ice hey but
to preserve the [__] your boy still here
and most my what was the recovery time
on that like a couple days really when
it hurts again you feel so much
better that sounds
wonderful was it through like the middle
the side or just the oh I didn't say
this part I forgot it's an automatic
nail gun
I never meant to imply Just One Nail
went through my dick the [__] yo fellas
they make these shits like what am I
fighting the predator or am I trying to
get this [__]
construction like it seemed like
hundreds to me it was only eight the
doctor said it was seven and a half a
little much a little excessive
skin is this even a functioning podcast
are you [__] with us right now yeah
six minute
lie a piece of [__] guys hey what a
[__] rise do
yeah the curon it's just uh fun all the
[__] no for real for real happen I
embellish parts of the story we lie here
I never went to the hospital and I still
have two life for in my CH I never
removed there's a piece of it just so
pinky damn what was this segment
supposed to be though worst pain worst
pain worst pain you we're on yeah we're
on topic on topic no that's good like
best bicep exercise actual wor I mean
the story the actual stor is so [__]
lame I fell off the [__] monkey bars
when I was seven and I broke my wrist
but it was like I bone pain before and I
was like oh [__] that's true okay okay
please give is the nail gun
story he told Jared's story my story
that actually happened to me he's all
the burning him out he's like stop this
is my story uh it was when my block wore
off after my ACL surgery so they gave
you the injection the block what's the
Block it's just an injection they give
you in like your lower back it's to make
sure you don't feel anything after the
surgery oh and they make sure to tell
you like take your pain medication at
this time or else in 24 hours the blocks
going to wear off and you're [__] and
I didn't take the pain medication dumb
ass redneck [__] you people are
used to really good at taking
medications I'll take them all while now
do itely as that's why I didn't do it
that's literally why I didn't do it I
was like my whole family's addicted to
this [__] I'm not going to [__] do
this so you're trying to not be a
stereotype yeah so but then it wore off
right at 24 hours W so I ended up
slamming like three or four vikin in
back to [__] work nothing happened
with the pain it just slowly got worse
for like 3 hours wow worst pain I ever
felt until an hour later when the
Vicodin constipated me so bad no then my
[__] backed up to the size of that
gatorade bottle oh my God and it was
hard and compacted in there oh so I'm
literally like my knee is in this brace
and I'm on the toilet and I'm trying to
[__] and I can't and the pressure of you
straining is getting the knee puffy
again and my [__] and then I take an
enema to get the [__] out of my ass cuz
it won't come out of my ass and it won't
come out because it's this big you
thinking asking about a story like this
now you got these Grimace faces it's
this big I mean I didn't know it was
going to go to his [__] right talking
about nail guns in your nuts and stuff
like that I don't know worst pain ever
what the [__] is this well I mean this
it's for the fans I'm just the host man
turd's this big butthole is this big you
know what I mean like it's physics yeah
it's not coming out so I have to shove
my finger up my [__] oh that's a Bart
move that's in you trying to pull it out
yeah I had to like chip pieces off of it
oh my God but it's still really hard
it's lit like as hard as it can the
vikin made it that hard yeah yeah really
yeah basically it pulls all the water
out of your intestines and it just
[__] makes everything super hard but
like and your colon um so I like get a a
piece off but then it makes it hard and
like sharp oh and and I like like suck
it back up into my ass you know and it
cuts the inside of
my my own [__] cut every now and again
you don't digest all the almonds you're
eating or whatever and on the way out
they like they you won cuz you ate them
but they're like hey [__] you on the way
out I'm L like the sink's here and I'm
on the toilet I'm like this and I'm like
my finger's in my butt and it's like
3:00 a.m. and my mom knocked said honey
you okay I'm like Mom Satan is real [__]
away real you need any help she
literally was like do you need help like
go away mom you know what's going on in
here it was bad sh how did you get out I
finally [__] and it tore my [__] you
know wow just the whole gatorade bottle
imagine that sliding out of your seen a
few with a blade at the end oh [__] man
damn I think you guys wi yeah this was a
competition oh I if it it wasn't
everything's a [__] competition it
wasn't but you know you guys win what
are you Bart look you got some stories
time of think that sounds when I was a
kid um I had crazy stomach pains to the
point where I had I couldn't go to
school you know and and I just thought I
had like some kind of stomach flu or
whatever and it was so bad I I didn't
[__] for like a week uh they took me to
get a ultrasound and you're pregnant
yeah I was pregnant they found my little
[__] just like right there and then she
goes M there it is right there it's
stuck and I had to take like they were
trying different kind of pills whatever
laxatives to get it out of my system and
they're like you need to eat fiber all
this [__] finally came out it was like a
small little dried up green thing yeah
backing me up but I couldn't also eat
either but I was like it was every day
my stomach was like [__] hurting I
thought I was going to die [__] for a
week and I didn't know what was going on
I was like in fourth or fifth grade and
when you're a kid you're just like this
is death what am I going to tell my
friends about this yeah I've been out of
school for so long and I go back they're
going to be like what happened I had a
big [__] you know like whatever just
taking a [__] yeah dude should have kept
it it's going to be so embarrassing that
was crazy having pneumonia as a child
was crazy too going to the hospital
coughing my lungs out oh please oh now
we're just this is begging this is
turning pathetic oh yeah I had a cold
once J Mike had seven Nails in his dick
how do you feel that had 18 [__]
nails in one part of my dick mother
[__] you're talking about having the
well you had to broke your wrist as a
kid over here his mom was pulling a
[__] tarantula size [__] out of his
ass see see how you guys win it's just
hard to compete with now it's just like
we've been through some pain yeah I
would say adult adult pain would be um
two would be one this guy you know when
you Spar a little too hard it turn a
little real and then he uh what sport is
this uh just karate like full contact oh
[__] getting hit in the face type of
[__] uh and then my my spleen got
sprained and ruptured so when he kicked
it I thought I had a broken rib out that
so that was like a that took at least 3
months to heal and oh yeah remember and
I I literally thought I broke something
it was some [__] up [__] but yeah I
would say that was that was probably a
bad adult one where you can't sleep and
another one was I had an a crazy eczema
attack from head to toe just middle of
Co too I don't know what was going on I
never had this as a kid but like your
whole body has it whole body dude Jewish
or something no Japanese my skin yeah
yeah I just I just uh some you know I
always had patches of it but one crazy
breakout it was going crazy it would
wake me up in the middle of the night
had to take a hot ass shower to cool it
down all this stuff and I was just like
is this going to be on my body forever
now and it lasted like 2 weeks yeah well
that's about it oh I remember the most I
have two most painful Memories One was
when I was a kid I think I was 7 years
old you know when you like ride like a
like those BMX bikes you like to jump
the curve is that something that you
guys all did or sufficiently athletic to
do that okay so you would jump the curb
and that's what you would do and you
would try to jump higher and higher
things and I remember there's this at my
neighbor's house there's like this
little planner and then there's like a
tree in it but then the I don't already
don't want to hear this the planner's
like this high now so I'm like okay
everything I've been jumping is like
this high so to jump this I need to get
real High I didn't go really fast I went
all the way back started pedaling as
[__] hard as I could I went up I
jumped and then my front tire hits the
planner cuz I didn't go over and then
all that force my nuts hit the bicycle
seat and my nuts drag across the bicycle
seat and I just remember going like my
[__] nuts got um like tore off I tore
I I pulled down my shorts and I just
looked I don't give a [__] it was so
much pain you don't care if there's
neighbor
yeah fet you have your dick out I pull
my shorts down I pull down my under I
look at my dick and you know when you
like fall in you scrape and there's like
a scab it was like that my the bottom of
my testicle was all red like this that
was the most painful and then the second
most painful was uh back in college me
and Joe we used to go to our gymnastics
center cuz there was like there like a
group of like trickers that would like
you know trickers they would do like
butterfly twists back flips kind of
stuff kind of yeah kind of and so I was
learning how to do a back flip my
friends it was a just don't get a hurt
back walking
a Jewish athleticism yeah so I was and
then so I was learning how to do back
flips and then um one of the coaches was
like you want to get 100 um in the
gymnastics room Barefoot then you want
to get 100 uh Barefoot on the grass then
100 with your shoes on on the grass and
you can do it anywhere and and you know
kind of how like the and one [__]
practice
sorry Jesus over time so You' like come
in and do like cuz it actually burns out
your apps it burns out your apps pretty
bad because when you jump like you're
tucking really hard so I'm okay cool
every time I go I'm going to go like
bang out 20 or 25 of them I was on my
way to maybe like 60 or 70 just Barefoot
and sometimes you know when you're like
you don't fully know the technique yet
you your body will just bail after 6
yeah don't bail always follow through I
go up for some reason I [__] bail and
in my mind I'm like why am I bailing I
come down and my foot which is Barefoot
goes straight into the floor like this
and I hear crack crack CRA crack CRA
crack crack oh [__] and then so it blows
up right away probably one of the few
times as an adult I I get like so much
pain in and tears you little [__] I
know and that's that's what happened
that's the voice in my head I'm like you
[__] crying little [__] I'm like
you're doing 10 more on one foot yeah he
did more he was like oh I think I broke
my toe and then he keeps going more and
I'm just like damn all right that's
hella Asian right there little [__] I'm
like and and you're only going to do it
on one foot so I was like
what
two oh my God I just kept doing it and
when I was done I couldn't even I would
untie all my shoelaces to it's the
loosest and I couldn't even put it on my
foot cuz my foot was so [__] swollen
dude if I was like the gymnastics coach
i' pull everyone aside point you out be
like you see this [__] none of
the rest of you are [__] adult men
the [__] out of my face that's a [__]
man I'm not even on the team exactly I'm
doing it
recreationally that's the kind of
dedication we need matter of fact young
man here's your division one gymnastics
scholarship so what you don't have that
kind of talent it's raw energy we want
yep and he broke something and both of
us
quit you're like I don't want to be the
next guy I'll be like that's enough I
don't need to do a backflip there's
plenty of Asians that do it already tons
those are the two most painful God damn
did you break stuff yeah yeah I ended up
have um getting like X-ray and like all
these micr fractures in in the what are
they
metatarsal it take for you to heal um it
actually doesn't you're not really in
pain unless you like stomp so in like
all back to
gymnastics straight to it the part that
hurt uh a lot was the physical therapy
and like grason part cuz then once it
heals it's like rock hard there's Scar
Tissue everywhere and then so your
mobility in your toe is like it doesn't
even move and then so now they're like
okay we got to [__] you know scrape
all this [__] and get your moving your
toes again and that was [__] painful
wow I do remember that that was crazy we
had a lot of stupid [__] back then who's
next I guess I'm next yes I don't I'm
fortunate enough to not have had too
many crazy uh injuries but this how I
got this ear was really [__] painful
cuz I drained it and it could look like
this and it was a couple months after I
drained it it and then I was doing some
sparring with the friend who was a lot
bigger than me what is the what is the
sport here this we were training for MMA
we're training for MMA and very foolish
nothing painful in MMA of course he
threw a left he threw a left hook and it
hit and he was wearing 18 Oz gloves and
the standard is like 14 16 oz so this
was like a really big glove and we're in
headgear he threw as soon as he made
connection with my ear I just felt blood
like fill up oh he popped your balloon
dude and cuz it looked like this and
then it looked like this oh it got
bigger that looks sweet by the way thank
you appreciate it uh for the record
people who know don't know this if you
are trying to start bar fights never
start a bar fight especially with an
Asian dude first of all and second of
all that ear means that [__] has
seen some [__] you haven't seen yeah but
I feel like two big guys like this could
[__] just no please I would run
[Laughter]
three
Miss leave him out but I remember like
the feeling of how sensitive my ear was
and like when I would move my head I
could feel it like sash around and even
that was just so painful like someone
just touching it I was like oh my God I
would cry like a little [__] you know
and they would drain it but it just I
remember them using like five or six
needles to how did they drain it is it
just at the gym Bro Science way or you
went Bro Science Bro Science just homies
doing each other cuz the first time I
did it I had a nurse that did it and I
was like I can't call her again cuz she
just fixed my that's why that one looks
like that one and that's why this one
[__] to do it I want a memory for
this [__] I don't want a nurse erasing
my lived history well I was trying to
make it go back to look like this like a
normal ear but it just never they [__]
it up and then it just got hard and then
it's the rest cuz their method was like
and it sucked even more because like I
wasn't that good at all so and I had
[__] up ears so everybody would be
like oh you must be really good and I
was like white belt ability they're like
oh [__] vide are [__] dope I'm I
appreciate it when they you it was
through the head like it it was pressed
in the head gear already or dude it just
as soon as it made contact it was so
[__] painful wow I just I never felt
anything like that ever and I was but
also I have nothing else to really
compare it to but but at that time I was
like this is [__] awful well you have
compared to like shin kick or getting
kicked in the [__] quad yeah like but
it's it's a different kind of pain you
know it's like but this it was just so
sensitive and it was like if anyone
touched it like if I bumped into
somebody it would hurt you like oh [__]
and it would it would just SOS around it
was really gross dud before I mean we
tried to do the [__] pulling out the
liquid and I was like [__] this it just
hurt a lot so I was what just let it
hard and it's going to go back too is
that the proper treatment like a balloon
up and you drain it but like the proper
treatment is to get [__] cauliflower
you're like a goddamn man and walk
around [__] but you know when it's still
soft cuz it's in the formative phase
once it hardens up you don't feel [__]
but if it's still soft remember like
like slow low passing with the ghee and
the ghee is like the nastiest gnarliest
material ever and it just scrapes on
your [__] ear but at that point
you're like in the Kill Zone so you
don't feel it much but if you're just
warming up and you're doing a technique
and someone knee slides on your ear
you're like it's just like just
everywhere dude even like moving like I
would shadow box and I'll be like okay I
got to like not move so much I got to
take a knee for a second and you felt
like such a [__] cuz everybody's
training and you want to be training
with everybody but then you're like my
ear I can't so you feel like such a
[__] I just feel like I've been
trained hard enough cuz I don't have any
of those you need run into walls brother
hard doors dude I just have hair to
protect it your hair is gorgeous be
honest with
you
h